auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge
[Musik]
das winter maryland silvia ottow marcus
burg seinem haus gewarnt dazu um ihren
traum vom haus am see für kirche und das
ganze noch hochschwanger mit denen
zurück die bis heute als vierköpfige
familie jona und paula so heißen die
beiden töchter von silvia und markus
2017 hatten diese ihr leben komplett auf
den kopf gestellt
sie verabschiedeten sich aus der schweiz
wanderten aus schweden ausrufung sich in
snuko ihr kleines paradies und gründeten
eine familie schafft
kurz entschlossen
außerdem bei auf und davon souvenirs
abschiedsschmerz und neuanfang
die auswanderer die ersten schritte im
paradies erleben
wasserrohrbrüche und andere
missgeschicke wie die helden die
alltäglichen katastrophen meistern
frohe kunde und hiobsbotschaften die
auswanderer auch größeren krisen trotzen
und männer und ihre maschinen worauf
sich männer beim auswandern wirklich
freuen
[Musik]
si
[Applaus]
mona vetsch und die souvenirs aus zehn
jahren auf und davon
[Musik]
marihuana erwischt
die ich kenne man ohne geld die vierte
runde
das ist sehr gut sogar die behauptung es
ist ja immer nur viele behaupten es
geschafft
nach zwei jahren sind auch in monaco
[Gelächter]
wohlig warme wohnung von buemi auf
anhieb wie krumme serie nicht in sicht
[Musik]
einander in cesee viele zuhörer bereits
gemerkt
er hat amerika ja wie man diese
bewältigt er und sei das darf nicht
passieren und jemand einfach geht
zweimal mit spielen und das mit später
passiert einfach mal schon der termin
für ihre matches an die tag und nacht
für die an den tag
herren 60 spezielle 300 super mitgemacht
und ausgewandert sind das einfach
wirklich 18 ko ist also sie bei gemacht
hochschwanger andere ich ja schon und
dann wenn es richtig wenn du dich das
was andere das ist irgendwie du bist
irgendwie trainer du bist so immer im
urlaub dann wünschen ist nicht so jetzt
muss ruhiger wir glück so und denke
manchmal doch wahrscheinlich alles
gemacht
sie erhärten sich dann fast ein jahr ist
es jetzt her
das abenteuer von der burg fahne hält
wir starten
wenn sie da wenn schon so wunderschöne
darstellung vom profi rasen also das ist
ganz ganz gut für mich das schönste wenn
man gesetz herzschlag das ist oder das
ist bewegt und natürlich schon so
unglaublich viel dass das jetzt
erwachsen und römisches klappte es bei
diesem schönen stadt nicht schon alles
mehr oder weniger egal ich habe vor noch
warten bis der herzschlag sehr das
andere ist zugabe
[Musik]
hier haben silvia und markus bis vor
drei jahren gearbeitet
im renovation fachbetrieb von silvias
eltern diese wollten die firma an die
auswanderer übergeben
ich kenne ein paar das geschäft vom
vater übernommen oder so was die die
hände weil einerseits mache und ich weiß
sie sind nicht glücklich
es gibt ganz viele wo lieber was anderes
machen würde wie der elterliche betrieb
über eine aber es ist halt
es stimmt für uns das ist das wichtige
bei mir in unser leben leben
fast vier jahre lang versuchten markus
unsleber den erwartungen der familie
gerecht zu werden
sevilla leitete er im betrieb die
finanzen den showroom und organisierte
die ausstellungen
markus war geschäftsführer
beide gaben vollgas in ihren shops ich
habe einfach gemerkt rallye markus das
ist eben nicht gut gegangen ist und
irgendein ist winter im holzlager noch
nie zum heiligen und irgend einmal müsse
einfach gestaltet dass verschiedene ich
einfach nicht aus wie schon erwähnt und
die kronleuchter die wette eigentlich
verkaufen
bei den schwiegereltern von markus wird
das abschiedsfest für die auswanderer
vorbereitet schwiegervater tee hilft mit
dem regen schutz
sie haben 40 leute eingeladen freunde
bekannte und silvias geschwister lang ja
sind dieses recht das bedeutet account
geklettert was man sie macht auch einmal
spiels limacher theo hat mühe damit
seine tochter nicht mehr in der nähe zu
haben
der plan ist dass der markus- und sylvia
ahlers kräfte und fiel bis 470 sehr gut
getarnt dass sie andere zukunftsplan
handwerk ein ums andere zuwanderer
hätten ihn überrascht will diesen
glamour welt der blogs also von dieter
spürt man ja eigentlich das ist schon
heftig
ich bin ja theo konnte die firma
mittlerweile verkaufen an einen
mitarbeiter aber hinzunehmen dass
sevilla und markus sie nicht
weiterführen wollten fiel ihm und seiner
frau beatrice schwer
die firma patient sucht geburt macht
denn es sind jährlich 52
aber er ist vor allem ihrem glück
[Musik]
euro
rufen
[Musik]
der ofen tv zeigen wir ein zwei oder
mehr zeit immer die wogen so wenig aber
es blieben aber immer lueg oder sowie
eltern und für deinen körper eigentlich
noch relativ wenig für ein älteres pizza
bisher gehört aber dass sie sich schwer
[Musik]
dem prozess jetzt oder andere glaubt
extrem viel erklärt ein älterer patient
ist eigentlich locker und einfach
kompromisslos unterstützt obwohl sie
eigentlich für euer andere banker hätte
ja ich glaube sie haben einfach immer
wieder hoffen ich kann mir keiner zurück
ja und danken ihr hättet euch schön ist
gemachte nest setzen das unternehmen k
man hätte eigentlich der rote teppich
ausgerollt dass ihr das alles einfach
glücklich gemacht haben und die muss man
sich gestorben
und da sind nicht stimmig und
unbehelligt schweiz nichts möglichkeit
das grundstück am wasser zu erwerben in
dem umfang und qualität und es ist
natürlich frei erfunden wird einer der
immer geschichtsverein traum
verwirklicht und als einfach schön so
wie haben sie das egoistische
[Musik]
keine liebe wäre nicht egoistisch dann
wäre mal verlegt mit glücklich hatte ich
keine kinder mehr pflichten mit seinem
als und seine passende musik und dann
patsch es ganz viele szenario erfinder
was wäre wenn der tourismus anders sieht
das der kabine
das ist ganz schön groß wanderer immer
wieder gesehen
das drehmoment um sich entscheidet da
muss ich einige zahllose und das ist zum
beispiel bärtige hermann wo kanada
englischer sogar de hat sich sehr
schnell
kurz bevor sich die schönbächlers auf
nach kanada machen ist herrmanns mutter
elisabeth zu besuch
[Musik]
es sollte ja irgendwie hat die schocker
ankaufen das würde so
für an die unsicherheit zu drücken und
noch mehr bizarre details gearbeitet das
war ja da hat man sich eigentlich keine
truppen stellungen hatte hecking mit dem
krad stark sieger aus
[Musik]
manchmal muss man auch abschied nehmen
von menschen die noch gar nicht bereit
sind verlassen zu werden
ja auch schon maries erste frau bringt
die mutter seiner kinder ist da und
natürlich auch die kinder samt anhang
und enkel samuel maries ältester sohn
tut sich schwer mit den plänen des
vaters
[Musik]
[Applaus]
naja
macht ihm immer gesagt dass ich mit
[Musik]
auch der espo net hat einen schweren
abschied vor sich bevor sie nach
venezuela auswandert sie besucht das
grab ihres sohnes daniel eines von zwei
kindern aus erster ehe die acht jahre im
alter von 23 jahren hat sich daniel das
leben genommen
mindestens einmal pro woche besucht sie
seitdem sein grab und besser
aufgeschlagen und jan ole kriegs im
prinzip immer noch am herzen
somit nehmen
[Musik]
häufig stehen egal wie die dauer ins
nocebo unbeschwerte sieht mit der vielen
verlängern und gefühl richtig
entschieden
all das hilft das der abschiedsschmerz
mitte zitiert
[Musik]
aber speziell die erste tag am neuen ort
sind für viele auswanderer mit gott
paradiesisch das neue leben von marcel
buholzer und seiner frau tricks beginnt
im dunkeln
sie sind in griechenland angekommen im
dorf beziehen sie eine wohnung
sie haben diese unterkunft während ihres
letzten aufenthalts in kreta gemietet
tricks wusste genau wie sie ihr nest in
griechenland einrichten möchte einige
dieser möbel hat sie extra noch in der
schweiz gekauft
[Musik]
wenn man eine inoffizielle und brauchen
nur theoretisch von dort besonders
fertig die neue schwangerschaften nicht
was ich mit einer kommode mit ihrer
mannschaft
sie hätten uns überhaupt konnte mir
selber nie cannabis motorisch 28
[Musik]
erstmals seit sie das anwesen im letzten
herbst gekauft haben reisen claude und
anja mit und kino in ihr neues heim nach
italien ihr hausen
der vorbesitzer ein engländer hat das
haus unaufgeräumt verlassen
sehr zur freude von chino dem trüffel
hund
naja da wir sind hier seit monaten kommt
matratze aufpumpen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein baby los schluss
nicole ist endlich in santa teresa das
dorf kennen die kinder bereits sie haben
hier ihre sommerferien verbracht
die beiden häuser haben nicole und mike
im internet gefunden und für drei monate
gemietet jetzt da nicole die unterkunft
zum ersten mal in realität sieht macht
sich ernüchterung breit
[Musik]
tragen
euro
gibt es hier nicht
marien das ist momentan nicht
angeschlossen was nicole vorher auch
nicht wusste die bungalows liegen
außerhalb des dorfes mitten im dschungel
es gibt nur ein kleines problem ich kann
den schlüssel nicht finden
aber morgen bringe ich ihn heißt es mit
dem licht das licht mache ich später
[Musik]
bruder wieder das volle leben flotte
sprüche können nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass die beiden häuser
nicht eben paradiesisch sind
[Musik]
ich mache aus nicht mit ja
so oblag es extrem wichtig
momentan sieht die beiden nur gäste in
ihrem eigenen guesthouse denn der
mietvertrag ist noch nicht
unterschrieben
20.000 dollar übernahme gebühr haben sie
mit max ausgehandelt ein stattlicher
betrag für monika und peter die für
ihren traum vom eigenen guesthouse ihre
pensionskasse aufgelöst haben
innerhalb von nur vier tagen haben
monika und peter damals entschieden dass
guesthouse zu übernehmen
länger kennen sie auch max nicht der
immer noch der aktuelle chef im haus ist
und der irgendwie nervös zu sein scheint
dunkel ist es frau in schweden aber
nicht etwa wie immer kamera minister
abstellen
im winter sind nicht da rabenschwarz und
lag am morgen macht sich der marksburg
parat zum geschaffen
nach der renovierungsarbeiten auf dem
hof snuko hätte marcus burg erzieht lang
für der astrid lindgren park schafft
inzwischen zieht ist china selbständig
unter ex-trainer roboter machen erst elf
die familie krumme vor der burg
diskutiert auch mit mit ausfahrbarer
mann ist marco wenn man etwas geschafft
markus immer aber wir sind immer noch
lernen das wird auch noch eine zeit lang
so bleiben dass man lernt wie schwede
funktioniert speziell jetzt bei mir wenn
er auf baustellen
das ist der umgang mit anderer handwerk
unsere sache verschrieben haben lernen
das ist halt
ja
anders
das dauer bist du wirklich drinnen
schmid ich gesät
[Musik]
jeder baum jahresziels tour mit
deformierten der zimmer jetzt aber
ruhrgas betrieb von dass wanderer
[Musik]
ja
pause
[Musik]
einschnitte für die im winter wenn in
erster linie das geht jetzt leben und im
sommer kann man ganz viele andere sachen
dazu wenn man diese formierte team viel
arbeit geht fast der ganze hof und jetzt
im winter ist es lästig dass ich besser
für verkehr
viel hat sich verändert sie ziel war
hochschwanger gar nicht so komisch aber
in seinem buch und als hätte sie sich
erst geburt vor yuma vorbereitet in
schweden steht die erste schwangerschaft
untersuchung an
der geburtstermin rückt näher
in der frauenklinik in wimmer will
silvia einen termin mit der hebamme
vereinbaren
[Musik]
si wier und markus haben einen stehtisch
grundkurs besucht und ein paar privat
lektionen genommen vollständig
[Musik]
silvia hat beschlossen direkt bei der
hebamme vorbeizufahren ehemann markus
kommt selbstverständlich mit
[Musik]
die auswanderer haben glück die hebamme
spricht englisch und nimmt sie spontan
zeit für eine erste sprechstunde
bisher verlief die schwangerschaft ohne
probleme dennoch sind die chips
vorsichtig silvia hatte bereits drei
fehlgeburten
[Musik]
man hört die herztöne aber da ist noch
etwas anderes
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also alles in ordnung
[Musik]
bis zur geburt wird die hebamme sie
regelmäßig untersuchen
[Musik]
juni ist jetzt zwei jahre alt und sucht
first roland hipp schulfrei
[Musik]
mit lockerheit mit der familie zu
gründen
das ist das ziel natürlich dass man in
das land könnte es kurzfristig systeme
tuner kann als tochter von baur vor
profitieren dass sie drei tage die woche
zur integration in der schule darf
obwohl ziel werner mutter zieht bezieht
spruch ist sensibel sein eigenes foto
sprachentwicklung und es läuft halt
siering und dann ist natürlich wichtig
dass sich spärlich jetzt also weiter zu
imitieren wie isoliert auf achse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der markt sich in der region ich hörte
steht ein name als schweizer qualität
schritt gemacht jetzt transfer hus
forscht in eigenregie umbauen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ist ja wohl eine deutsche
makler kennengelernt
da hier aber tätig ist führt mit sprache
gefunden und daher ist hier verkauft und
ist ein schweizer kunden da hat mich
dann empfohlen mal gesprochen und sie
haben mich halt im fernsehen
und dann kann man uns mal treffen und
passt dann bereits als wären wir
der markus profitiert jeden tag von
ihrer guten ausbildung und eppe mal über
unterschiede als zwischen schweden und
schweizern rustikaler sie sind jetzt so
viel wie ein schweizer im prinzip also
schöne gärung oder schön verarbeitet die
oberfläche versteckt so oft ist einfach
wirklich eher spartanisch man guckt über
dem fenster
die fenster sind alle gleich spitze
schräg und anfällig und in der schweiz
reklamiere aber jetzt schon in die hose
rutschen jedoch daran oder koks aus dem
fenster gefallen hat das schön sie sind
jetzt abhängig
die bank sei wenn du wenn du probierst
den schweizer grint hierdurch zutritt
durch das geordnet du musst dich musste
eine qualität walter aber dieses diese
diese diese wäsche für diese lockere
frisch weder mit ihnen nur zu gut machen
haben recht mittlerweile ja
[Musik]
hey ich versteh ja oft so erhält durch
die haus und das nächtliche baute mir
sicher oliver schäfer wenn frau die
stürze mit enttäuschte und im winter
machen wir diesen winter schlafen was
macht ihr das nicht möglich also ich
empfinde das als großer luxus
warum das ist wo ich finde dass ich das
privileg benötigen sie könnte so einer
mit ja und so eine wiener hätten wir uns
mal begleitet sie velemir ihre hörner
zeige
[Musik]
das team ist gut
ich lade händler da jetzt haben wir
immer mein tag das ist absolut perfekt
perfekt die menge der wehrpflicht denn
auf den frühling schon nach liebe zu tun
dass man genau
für mich ist wichtig mit terminierten in
der region auch und takt dass
jugendliche spielen namen orten
mittlerweile aber sind so viel braucht
also nicht was es gibt natürlich dass
die winterspiele und die erste partner
sagt sie ja
mich hat nicht so viel zu hoch und ich
will vielleicht auch am falschen ort
hören es gibt ja verschiedene die
richtigen und dann habe ich mir überlegt
die könnten auch probieren und so
plötzlich ist eingegangen also
verschiedene ist auch probiert
verschiedene norden
[Musik]
wenn der herr und dankte sie schaut
darauf passiert
[Musik]
förderer und sozialrecht
doch wie würde
[Musik]
und was hat gott interviews
geht nicht gibt's nicht stark genug sei
das glaube ich schon mal irgendwo anders
so viel leid und alle daran dass sobald
du die ganze zeit sich so markus der
gelernte schreiner macht sich ans werk
schwedische möbel zusammen setzen sich
zudem an die macht der regen
abgeschreckt und die matratze die mir
hän heißt auch mit logik wie heiße
hammerweg bleibt letztlich scheiterten
aber bisher nicht verhängt
das kommt mir gefällt was langsam
dämmert es markus ja ich hab das glaubt
er hat das bettgestell falsch montiert
ist möglich sagt mir dass unser bitter
weil ich das nicht durch und außen
gleich ist damals nach und und sascha
rettig ist fast alles schuldig und für
slawik ich habe mich einfach für der
arabic erziele anstatt für logisch ist
da ja natürlich
wenn man bedenkt dass machen
[Musik]
also es gibt drei sache bei der szene
er hasst die variante ich habe
grundsätzlich entschuldige mich dass ich
wecke falsche rokoko ich bin einfach der
fokus und walter aktiver es ist zweitens
nicht falsch montiert es war einfach zu
verkehrte richtung habe nur fürs
verkehrt herum habe noch nutzen wird für
heute und das ist ein mini kollege so
haben wir sagen können dass er als
zuständiger minister
aber was mich wundert er hat mir vor
erzählt dass du die ganze summe auf das
angesprochen oder 6 und wächst
mittlerweile oft nicht rechtfertigen
muss ich einmal sagen und ihr heimlicher
mit dem konfrontiert was der hersteller
dass ich also großartig sie dass ein
richter hat das sehr gut ich hab ich
glaube das ist eine faire weise als
trainer nicht derjenige wo das
möbeldesign
egal welches möbel er hat es ja so die
sein dass es klein schnuckelig verpackt
wird
das ist logisch montiert wird also du
also es du musst als trainer
zwangsläufig auf das den kopf ich fand
es arrogant als stehen und sachbuch kann
montageanleitung die brust das ist ja
ich habe gehört dass alle de lüt und
sind flexibler absuchten station durch
die rechnung ist verschenkt das ja und
anhänger ein klassisches anderes bild es
ist ganz bitter ist das wird meine das
ist jetzt einfach jungs halten
billig und durch stützt sich hast du ne
da in szene kite glaube ich jeder jede
familie wo es gerade stehen irgendwo
sondern moment was war das leben lang
werden gesprochen werden uns bald einig
sehen wir jetzt graben verlegt
auch hier war ein scheiß nicht zum
glauben es nervt mich ja wo wir bereits
heute wollen alle schinken mit ein
[Musik]
das festhaus ist seit kurzem eröffnet
das schinken und ei frühstück wurde bis
heute noch nie gestellt
[Musik]
vielleicht alles links ruft sich schon
heute
der verschafft nein das spielt man
[Musik]
inzwischen auch der kleine sven kann es
kaum erwarten das papier wieder da ist
nur zeigt er seine vorfreude auf ein
wenig andere art hallo
wo deine das sagte klose
das nächste wandel ein thema zieht sich
wie ein roter faden durch die
auswanderer geschichten wasserrohrbrüche
rund um den erdball die geplante
sanierung des badezimmers hat nun
oberste priorität
[Musik]
der verein will jetzt nicht mitreden
über twitter und karubi und mir genau
wie geht immer auch durchaus gesund oder
erschießen
ein wasserrohr ist geborsten direkt vor
der hoteltüre
wieder muss monika warten und diese
warterei erträgt sie kaum mehr sind die
stars der serie komische werk
jetzt freue ich mich einfach um 707
abwasserschacht hiphop de
[Musik]
hier haben christian und sein
mitarbeiter mirko vor kurzem den
wohnwagen an die abwasserleitung
angeschlossen sowie dadurch steckt um
mehr kosten als wenn wir schon das ist
dann dürfen wir hier wieder oder ja wie
gern ich schnell schufen aber nicht mit
der hand von solchen großen stinkt
gemachte zeit zum fremd nein das war
nicht ein großer stinkt das war die
dummheit von mirko und papa ja aber ich
glaube dass wir da etwas machen
schonungslos re optimist
optimismus aufsteigers lebte wie der
erinnerung wieder soli zweifel der
vorstände aber wenn man natürlich war
ich und bestraft familie gründen und das
sind so viele unsicherheiten
ja das macht ein mann gestorben
das wirklich alles zerbricht das ja
eigentlich vom staat ja die
existenzangst und ich bin der
markusstraße womit r3t oder
mitgeschleift
ja ich habe einfach die möglichkeit
vorbereitet ich habe bei kurs besuchte
ich auch mental training machten einfach
mit positiven denkens und habe mir auch
wirklich wie wir durch das habe das
immer kämpft die trichter bis zum
goldenen es wird alles gut es
funktioniert alles es gibt keine
frühgeburt das gab nichts kaputt ich hab
mir wirklich wie ein mantra dass er
selber gedacht habe es wirklichkeit
schneider hat mir wirklich zittrig tat
selber einfach nur so
es gab eben speziell ich glaube das
macht doch lust bei anderen auswanderern
irgendwie die ungeschnittene castro
hilflos so sind wir schweizer aber sie
richtet sich auf alles problems konnte
ganz anders in der so lang wie sie kein
verbindliches permanent resident sie
überholen dass ihre bewegung dass sie
mich darauf in kanada blieben und wo es
dann endlich so wie sich alles so wie es
muss sie aber jetzt gibt es wieder
neuigkeiten zweiter gute und zu machen
darüber einig dass ich deutlich weniger
freut
ja
einiges hat sich ändere die letzten
september positive das ist die so
genannte diese straf- und der
aufbereitung kräftig bitte firma die
ganze wirtschaft in bleiben wie es ist
und ich habe mir sind da wohl winterzeit
stark stellten auch für mich anal mit
einer maschine anschaffen und da nur
sagen
die neue maschinen und investment sa las
ich wieder verkauft und da war es ihre
woanders mehrere duisburgs hat sich
aufgemacht zum ein kanadischer baums
fürchtet lehre mit spezialmaschinen
küste und volks kanada erfolgreich in
der holzwirtschaft mitspielt und das
unternehmen spart bis zu botschaften
ruhig
gewinnt der geschäftszeit party sowie
und den stolz macht greift die nahezu 23
da seitdem so volker das in der ganzen
provinz agri gestoppt worden sind ab
werk abgestellt und so wiesen fall etwas
böses werk komplett ab stellt also wir
immer mehr stellt ich wäre sofort wieder
zu jetzt eigentlich wieder zurück aber
es ist einfach mein auge schweiz man
fangen wieder bei null an und und
magnetischen momenten holzwirtschaft
auch nicht einfachen und da alles musste
ja welche doch auch ein bisschen daran
account und viele sachen wo man es halt
doch wie sieht ihr und ich sie das land
und die ganze sache
die haben halt einen schweizer auch
nicht das wäre schienen sitzen über
briefwahl fox sieht somit sehr gern mal
wieder zurück und anna-maria super und
jetzt machen wir das machen und
irgendwie absolut planlos zunächst mal
bei de kmg die idee ich denn aus
irgendwelchen gekrönten unser fundes
funktioniert nicht und das funktioniert
nicht denn das funktionieren
und jetzt mittlerweile als eigentlichen
plan und ja das macht sie zwar wieder
positiver zu sorgen
jetzt wissen wir wenigstens wiesweg
gebaut und so packen das noch mal
probieren ja selber so wir haben mit der
maschine mit der termin der arzt einen
fehler macht spezial spezial arbeit
dafür haben die unternehmer oder für für
die stadt bestimmt sport.de
lagen für stromleitungen pipelines ist
es endlich einmal schlichtes mama wenn
ich meine hände jetzt kriegen wir jetzt
wenn man schläft nicht und tourismus
mache ja größer weil mir uns war über
ihren abenteuern begleitet als das im
raum dass mehr privat die und fast
intime situationen zeigt und die ganze
schweiz sorgte wie zu das kann durchaus
konsequenzen haben die protagonisten
schön mühsam es ist einfach stellen
fertig und selber plötzlich zur
attraktion wird das ist schon nach liebe
freundin also wir sind sehr überrascht
über wie nachhaltig das reaktionen sind
wir hoffen sie noch zwei männer tv
sailauf kurzlebig um gleich ein riesiger
ansturm wie lange das ist ja dass
reaktionen aber auch unter seien dafür
reaktionen klarzukommen sie dass
irgendjemand einfach schritte toll glück
und gratulation viele hatte mal ein
junger augen gemacht und dann haben halt
vor allem ganz viele karte einfach
fahren und eine tür klopfte gesagt den
soli zu na ja und er mag formal deshalb
noch orange money marco einmal zum
kaffee trinkt ist einmal zweimal dreimal
und man ist immer weg wurde und dann ist
leider ab und zu mal weniger
aufdringlich sie anmerkt mittelmärker
irgendwann wir können nicht alle halbe
stunde immer grund der heute seinen
kaffee trinken also es geht ja nicht nur
um die uhr hand und wenn das ständig
über das grundstück kauft mit der
handykamera werden
also das heißt wir sind jetzt ein fixie
sehenswürdigkeit dagegen
silvia und markus schiene drei mit der
situation gut tun sco über das jetzt den
part wo wohnungsbau werden sollte sollte
ja ducati nie maschine tatsächlich zum
schaffen wo diese mit mitte meist
anderer mann findet wo es gar nicht sind
cool sind ausgewandert sie sich ebenso
eines spezielles fahrzeug auf
super summer night sie mehr freut wie
ich also ja ja ja das ist marcus
ein rasenmäher natürlich ein aufsetzer
mit allradantrieb
ohne vier mal vier ging es nicht
die steigerungen auf dem gelände wollen
bezwungen werden
[Musik]
als wäre es ein naturgesetz männer und
ihre maschinen
natürlich kann sie auf diesen jahres
das ist okay geben
[Musik]
auch mike riedner hat sich für ein paar
extras pferdestärken in rot entschieden
[Musik]
die ukraine eingestellt
wer hat den vorhin gebrauch
[Musik]
da ist doch mal musik rot-gelbe wichtig
dass er weiß wie das läuft wo lärm und
rauch ich kraft
[Musik]
ja
hoffmann
[Musik]
endlich steht der arbeit nichts mehr im
weg oder besser gesagt fast nichts
[Musik]
auslaufen müssen maschinen kapo
in slubice im winter sollte und wenn der
nummer kurz also strom ein doppelter
genuss dort auf linie paradies spazieren
erzählt er und marcus sorg scharf
verhängt
ganz ohne meinungsverschiedenheiten
sabine begann das eintrittstor
unterschied zu viele sind advent tapete
und alte möbel richtig machen ich habe
dadurch gewiss aber ich glaube es gibt
nichts damit mehr frauen ins kino sind
ebooks voller tatendrang
schon bald wollen sie hier
ferienwohnungen vermieten
bewertet der unfälle und diskussionen
ich war dafür dass martelly würden wir
es noch gebrauchen oder lassen ihre dass
sie aus albert und markus stähli lämmer
und holz dass es mehreren tranchen
ich bin einmal einer des
wirtschaftsjahrs machen und dann lüge
wie sie musik und das theoretisch kamera
das und dann müsst ihr einfach nur
machen kann so praktisch darum ist
liefert der kontrast zu dem vorstoß will
es ist einfach noch linie sei froh dass
man so viel helligkeit wie möglich im
übrigen ohne zu machen
nein es wird nie wies wurde blieb thema
holz und delhi würde man rasieren
ihr würdet struktur klar kann man die
warmen machen was mir machen
ich das combo mit seinem schluss ziel
wer sagt dass ihr mache das ist der
kompromiss
[Gelächter]
nein es ist eigentlich in dem moment da
kompromisse einfach so dass ich gewusst
hat man müsste strich aber haben absolut
keine lust weil ich im moment einfach
die andere tixier größter das tablett
darunter tablette hoch google muss ich
mache die ganze möbel und dann gedacht
ach du musst jetzt mit sie ohne
stressige zu entschädigen müssen jetzt
diskutiert wo du entscheiden muss aber
ich glaube so in sachen umbau ist das
die einzige kommune ganz zahm ixia ja
das ist so aber es ist uns gut gelungen
druck
der russe war wie eine achterbahn gute
stellen
ja das ist so du musst du musst die
opensocial ja nicht nur als partner über
chemie als also da muss halt auch
irgendwie jeder muss sich auf ein jahr
bezogen und das ziel so dass bestand wie
das team wohl einfach das ziel hat und
dann musst du dich also das ist die
beziehung das ist einfach müsse
funktionieren das ist jedem ein twin
server produkte aus basel daheim nicht
mehr groß raden beziehungsdreieck machen
die berufswahl haben und das ist
vielleicht mein geschäftsfeld zieht es
zum studieren uns vor bewusst darüber
geredet wie stritten mir ganz einfach so
ist - das ist mehr als größtes wird das
turnier startet das gibt situationen wo
oder amerikanischen erhalt ganz dumm
bist aber du musst einfach glaubt du
musst einfach respekt die gegeneinander
war
und schlussendlich es uns stärker
gemacht
[Musik]
silvia unter markus ein raser die erste
bewährungsprobe sandra bravourös
gestreckt vor anderen usa wisse man dass
er drei jahre nachdem auswanderern und
die eine oder andere profi konrad wolf
und der vor souvenirs business wanderer
nachfragetrend wie sie in allen an
dieser gott einzig das skate abmelde
trixi dieses mail geschrieben und seit
jahren groß sie eigentlich nötig bis
freunde bei ihnen äußert der champions
in die braucht sie selber täglich zu
unheimliche probleme es bei halter
klemmt und die mass effect spital müsse
für den bypass daher muss ich doch nur
derer an die oktober operation kann und
der jüngste medienschelte und
prozesskette der nach trafen romy space
frame vier monaten komplett aus die vier
monate lang im bett sie zu thrombosen
steht da konnte man sich mal vorstellen
sie funktioniert nach wie vor nicht oben
ohne punkt so nicht richtig
aber sie hält fahrer weniger als eine
frau weniger und der große respekt
so jetzt sind die nähte röhren ersetze
das operiert ist sensationell es
bedeutet ja ja und genau das bringt so
sachen erlebt wo es gibt viel schlimmer
hätte das evangelium so funktioniert wie
zeitpunkt sei aber nie die schweiz ist
schon groß gang des cases als ruhige
gebiete in deutschland rohrrahmen jedes
jahr und danach alle mit der gratis
andrangs am 8
bürger zu mehr und der anlage ist für
die situation in anderen machen und
negativ sehen konnte den ball aber neben
negativen positiv aber sogar negative
[Musik]
aber nur negativ denken
wer auswandert muss renoviert für oslo
schließlich möchte die meisten us
wanderer am neuen ort miteinander alt
und glücklich werden
für welches land für wenig kultur und
auf ihre gesundheitssysteme sich
entscheidet
warum ist es eigentlich absolut nicht
behaupten konnte stellt sich jetzt
natürlich sofort ist das schön diese
praxis überhaupt nicht sexy
wir sind eigentlich umgekehrt vorgang
sehr stück weit mit ihren endlagern
alltag und auf grund von dem haben wir
denn eigentlich gerückt weil das land
bietet diese möglichkeit aber was jetzt
so ich glaube viel findet skandinavien
roma das gefühl hat es relativ ein loch
jetzt also ist das für ein argument das
gesagt wir werden nicht eine total
andere kultur das ist noch interessant
dass marius mit europäer das gefühl die
sind recht eigentlich will ich muss also
was verschlossenes mir also wir mehr
geld ja schon alles kontrolliert und die
strophen versichert wenn du bist einfach
eine sprecherin du bist einfach
automatisch per du ja das passiert und
das wird also zum kennen lernen
funktioniert das ein recht gnädig du
musst du nicht mal kurz mit silizium das
ist einfach klar dass immer noch wir
haben aber kompromisslos spielt glaubt
irgend eine art basis an andere kultur
hat wie jede und jeder vor seiner
auswanderung
er zieht das gemacht karte ich mache das
alte andere denkst du ich glaube gut so
da muss doch andere länder andere sitten
landestypische rituale und religiöse
zeremonien stellen wir unsere schweizer
auswanderer regelmäßig echte
herausforderungen dar
[Musik]
auch anni kuhn und orlando stammen haben
auf bali das ganze dorf zu einer
farbenfrohen einweihungszeremonie
eingeladen
denn genau ins eck diese rituale zu
beschreiben fällt jedoch nicht immer
ganz leicht zu alle skeptisch und alles
böse weg dass gäste willkommen sind
genau darf auch und das ist jetzt der
glaube der jüngsten gesegnete saale
häuslichen gesegnet dass alles im iglu
soll sie mit gut und schlecht gehen aus
der balance sagt stimme es wäre
eigentlich parat würde fürs business ja
dass geldströme und diesen ton versucht
sich jetzt schwer leicht erleichtert ich
sehr richtig aufwärts böse kann man
gratis ist der segen der götter freilich
nicht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
neben religiösen eigenheiten sind hin
und wieder auch essgewohnheiten samt
zubereitung gewöhnungsbedürftig anni
kuhn und rolando stamm bietet sich an
diesem tag ein besonderes schauspiel in
einem hinterhof werden unmengen an
opfergaben für das große eröffnungsfest
vorbereitet
[Musik]
unser gewünschtes durch in thailand
haben lange und hans jäger ungebetene
gäste auf ihrer baustelle ist auch wir
großen wert auf helvetische
gepflogenheiten auf der baustelle legt
sollte sich das auswandern gut überlegen
weil man die auch roboter von beton
diese der uni hagen syrien besser
unterbringen
heute ist niemand darum schäfer und der
co es heißt darum pinke er auf ist ein
unter der horten minuten fertig tawakoli
mir kommen oder aber jetzt kann sie auch
so hotelbesuch gibt's immer dabei es
braucht gar nicht immer kühner sichtbar
zu machen dass auf manchen baustellen
dieser welt andere maßstäbe gelten
aber ist es nicht zum fenster
[Applaus]
decker ist ziemlich hoch sein wenn der
keller scheint zu tief zu sein
entsprechend sind die fenster zu hoch
gesetzt das wäre ein desaster denn die
keller ihres hotels wollen die beiden
künftig wohnen
[Musik]
werthan konsultiert die baupläne auf
seinem handy
wie man sich bettet so liegt man sagt
das sprichwort
nur scheint das keine mexikanischen
redensart zu sein bevor die auswanderer
den ersten spatenstich machen können
stehen schwierige kaufverhandlungen
bevor
nicht immer geht das einst gesprochene
wort
[Musik]
die anwältin begrüßt claudio
überschwänglich claudio ist blendend
gelaunt noch
[Musik]
dann denkt kommt damit erlebt
gar nichts klappt in der kanzlei
erwartet sie keine unterschrift fertiger
vertrag und auf der abgemachte preis
gilt plötzlich nicht mehr
statt 370 mio
unverrichteter dinge ziehen claudia und
teresa platzt bereits jetzt der traum
vom eigenen haus
er schlidderte in diesem raum dreimal
mehr als ursprünglich abgemacht dass
sind 60.000 franken
so viel müssen die beiden für ihr
grundstück bezahlt
heute wollen marcel und tricks die
weichen für ihr neues leben stellen in
ihrer tasche verbot tricks dafür ein
dickes bündel scheine
so ist es bei gut was man mit dem geld
geht's zum anwalt dort unterzeichnen
marcel und tricks den pachtvertrag der
anwalt erwartet das ehepaar bereits im
büro in seinem wohnhaus
ich bin die beste bank
[Musik]
das geld bekommt der vorbesitzer der bar
als ablöse für das inventar müssen sie
40.000 euro bezahlen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist wochenend silvia und markus
telefoniert mit der ältere burg in der
schweiz die una möchte eine großeltern
erzählen dass sie in kuba ein schneemann
[Gelächter]
sowie das für das die schweden
ausgewandert sind
das wieder so aber was handys quiz mit
säcken wieder zurecht dass ein gütiges
die treffen
[Musik]
das ist aus mir gemacht hat und ich
glaube das ist geburtsrecht also ich
meine sagt glaube ich auch viel damit
nur über den delta das gefühl kennt das
man das ist ja wie ist das bei ihnen wir
sehen ja eigentlich für zwei ganz andere
pläne wirst du verstehen sie wird findet
diese bieten steht für sie habe silvia
zentrum mini eltern sind beide so
geworden dass mir hat für unser glück
selber verantwortlich sind und
dementsprechend haben wir für unser
glück liegt und sich das land jetzt aber
es war ja auch nicht gut wenn wir bei
ihnen in der schweizer währung wäre
traurig und sie wurde immer mit uns
konfrontiert jedes und igor letzten
kaffee treffen das ich eigentlich dazu
sondern ausbauen
auf der philippinischen insel palawan
ist auswanderer jörg seien auf
einkaufstour
alleine seine frau birgit ist in der
schweiz
sie wurde von so starkem heimweh gequält
dass sie zurückkehrte vorläufig für
einige monate york seien hingegen fühlt
sich auf der insel wohl ganz ganz kurz
berühren kauf gründlich gemacht
überhaupt
lux frau ist über 10.000 kilometer weit
entfernt im zürcherischen glattbrugg hat
der g10 unterschlupf bei ihrer tochter
lia gefunden
vorübergehend arbeitet sie in einen
kindergarten
ich bin nicht ich bin nicht ausland
kompatibel bestens das einzige was nicht
passt
[Musik]
sein wunsch gleich machen das resort und
bin plötzlich seien durch als toni
draußen hockte
jetzt sind wir erst das ist nicht viel
unverstand von alemao wilde maus mal
weniger gespürt
also ich sowieso wenn es noch mehr gott
musikbetrieb das gästehaus von studis
war in den letzten wochen ausgebucht
doch tue dies gegen auf
danke für ihre für patricia war die
sehnsucht nach tochter natascha zu kurz
jetzt reist auch beck bäckerin sarah
[Musik]
bush
den teil
unterm strich dort sind gut die co
[Musik]
und da weder gut für ich mich
23 mal alle krankheit die struktur sind
claudio candrian und theres poland ruhm
sind zu wenig zu allen tricks i10
sträuben die sachen erlebt todesmutig
rennt er es nach draußen um die diebe zu
stellen schmerzen oder was auch immer
druck macht zum glück nur sehr
streifschuss kräfte die ganze laden
geschoben
dies sagt sie habe an diesem geburtstag
ein zweites leben geschenkt bekommen
und mit der allgegenwärtigen
kriminalität müsse man halt leben lernen
der sport trägt er es und claudio immer
noch obwohl es regelmäßig nachrichten
über die verheerende zur steins
venezuela erreichen das land befindet
sich in ihrem miserablen der leiter geht
rhume lebensmittel und andere elementare
götter trafen
und trotzdem sind die beiden bündner
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gewünscht dass wenigstens sie haben
genau neun der rezitator komische gefühl
versucht so sicher wie du bist nur wenn
wir sie auf facebook konnte er nach
harbin in den showroom verschraubten
einziger dann auf oder ich denke dass
sie jetzt sauer auf dass die nordische
behauptet sie
turbulente zieht ist noch untertrieben
in venezuela ist ausnahmezustand
längsten sonntag demonstrationen
zusammenstöße zwischen bürger und
polizei nicht mehr erinnere das paradies
bucerius unter claudio 6 uhr stand es
wunderte dass die zwei immer motors hat
wobei der claudio zwischenzeitlich schon
mal als baum ohne die der schweiz
verbraucht hat und ernsthaft über seine
zukunft nachdenken
[Musik]
die schweiz liegt damit finanziell 36
schweiz mittlerweile 17 katzen an hohen
und der tannenhäher mit vier biberli so
nur mit zwar leid nah mit drei über die
roma eskaliert
da setzte sich gebracht und sie selber
mondwasser den awards geld im gegensatz
zu theres sie geht und die stimme von
sänger und gesagt das ist das ist lange
um den heißen südamerika großen handy
wirklich alles kann das darf es so
abwärts geht
das hätte nicht einmal träumt aber jetzt
stehen wir nicht verlottern geglaubt als
ich noch nicht ganz im sinn
ich bin glücklich mit material
historisch von morgen geben sich gedacht
wenn er bestätigt sehen dass sie daher
klar wieso kann ja das auch nicht denken
konrad strömt diene größte sie über
schwede litern frieden war sehr gut tut
familie burg macht sich bereit für ein
ausflug an den wunderschönen ort gespart
wie der ausflug
do
wer nämlich for snooki obwohl die
autostunden richtig oster fahrt wird man
zu der berühmte scherer
das sind einfach linie und felsenküste
wo der sz und kniffe wurde sind beliebt
die von dem fantastischen ort laut
förmlich dazu zu machen über's erreicht
die nerds denken
[Musik]
rückblick und weißt du noch zwei jahre
sind überrascht wie gut das klappt
so wie hertie-sprecher das ist wie es
war
[Gelächter]
du hoffst du hoffst dass es einfacher
gott aber du weißt ganz genau es wird
hart 15
und während diese einfach geil war sein
doch kunden im us wanderer
[Musik]
und genau darauf nahm noch glück zu
racing action abenteuers mit neuen
geschichten vor
[Musik]
an der rauen nordsee wieder sascha und
prickelt kunst ihre große chance um
sparsamkeit am wattenmeer übernehmen sie
einen imbiss mit currywurst und pommes
für ihren traum gibt die fünfköpfige
familie ihr heim im baselbiet auf
von frühjahr bis herbst stehen sie
hinter der free tisch
das geschäft steht und fällt mit dem
wetter
kein familie kunst tatsächlich von
würsten frikadellen und vom freckleben
familie almeyda aus dem kanton zürich
zieht es in den osten kanadas unter
tränen brechen sie ins neue läden auf in
der provinz nova scotia übernehmen die
armee das ein modell aus den 60er jahren
ich glaube so wunderten oder hilfen
[Musik]
rudi und zu sein althaus stürzen sich in
südamerika ins abenteuer
[Musik]
sie gehen auf und davon richtung wobei
das sieben zimmer haus im emmental indem
sie ihre drei buden aufgezogen hatten
tauschen ruhe die un susan vorerst gegen
einen container in der pampa die lippen
zusammen und leben zu zweit auf 14
quadratmeter agro
die neue staffel von auf und davon
übermorgen auf sf 1
[Musik]
wichtige brücke mit das alkoholdrama
die auf höchstem niveau
sid
[Musik]
damit drang so kurth hatte auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
fonds